[Music]
I'm at the Hollywood pawn shop in
Glendale California over the years I've
built up a lot of memorabilia I thought
I'd come here in person see if I can't
trade some of it in make a lot of money
because I'm told there's no way to do
this over the Internet what is your name
Sarkis very nice to see you and I'm Jax
my brother this is your brother were you
guys from Armenia you're from Armenia
very nice
I love Armenia no don't worry about it I
just said I loved it to be polite go
visit there but don't stay too long
really Yeah right what happens if you
stay too long great so you work for the
Armenian tourists come visit us but
don't stay too long good that's not safe
guess what my assistant is our mean Ian
Sona maybe you could tell them what it's
like working for me for Conan O'Brien
tell them in Armenian in Armenian us
Marta
shut frente he is an awful awful man
who's buffoonery tortures me on a daily
basis I know embarrassing secrets about
his life that I will use to blackmail
him and get a lot of money
and the only reason I still work for
this white devil right yeah good guy
good guy okay gentlemen I'm here to do
business
all right I am a celebrity and I thought
maybe I could pawn some of my
memorabilia here today and make some
money
Conan O'Brien headshot right sure I'll
sign it
how much twenty-five dollars but it's
got my signature what if I write
something on it like what what if I
admit to a murder if I say I yes I did
commit that murder you'll never catch me
Conan O'Brien dude that's a document
it's proof of a murder yes give me a pen
I committed murder
how much 125 125 okay really that's all
I get for my signed confession of murder
Conan O'Brien GI Joe the GI Joe made by
the GI Joe Factory don't know why it's
wearing kneepads embarrassing now I was
hoping to get $12,000 so it can tend to
help you $500 would say more like
tornadoes 220 okay 220 one of a kind
masturbating bear
[Applause]
now we know your technique
[Applause]
$35,000 $25,000 50 bucks
this is the world's tallest dachshund
[Laughter]
here's what I'm asking
125,000 dollars I need it in cash we
can't do it you shouldn't do it and you
know we're not interested okay is it
because it's a living animal between us
would have you know I brought him back
in an hour and he was stuff this song
seems a little scared right now you know
why you have a Michael Vick poster back
there
[Applause]
it's me it's made of various spare metal
parts and when you turn the crank it
does the same little dance I do at the
top of the show $800,000 $800
it's pretty good this is possibly one of
the greatest paintings in the world this
could hang in any Museum I don't even
want to talk price for a second I just
want you to stare in wonder
well who's in the booths in the painting
that's me you don't think I look like
that no it's clear that you want this
painting and you're playing some kind of
ball trick on me you're very good
I admire you $2,000 $2,000
okay hey guys I have one more thing to
show you guys
behold the largest bobblehead in the
world this is priceless to even put
money money figure on this is insane I
would like to start at 6 million and
then move up from there 6 million dollar
is there's a lot of money for a bubbling
$10,000 $10,000 okay Sona I need you I
want six million dollars for the
bobblehead they are saying 10,000 I
would like you to tell them what you
think this is worth and how much you put
would prize the bobblehead use your own
thoughts and your own words
I will not edit you in any way and go
he's sooo not what an [ __ ]
[Applause]
you